so I'm going to turn this over to
someone Kim and he's gonna take you
through teaching pubchem so I'm gonna
turn over to him hello everyone thank
you very much for joining us today for
next 20 minutes or so I'm going to talk
about how to use pubchem in the
chemistry classroom so what is pop camp
pop camp is a public chemical
information resource at NIH basically
what it does is to collect chemical
information from hundreds of data
sources in the public domain and
disseminate it back to the public free
of charge top camp is a very popular a
chemistry website for example last March
we had more than 2.9 million unique
users then who are our users generally
speaking about 1/2 of our users are aged
between 18 and 24 and those in this age
group are likely to be college students
and many of them are required to take
some chemistry courses like general
chemistry or organic chemistry then you
may wonder how they use pubchem the most
common use case of pop camp is search
through Google people go to google to
search for a chemical by name and
usually it gives a pop come record near
the top of the search result then people
click it to go to pop camp and get the
information they need basically students
are using pop chem as a reference
material like CRC Handbook were Berks
index essentially this has been a
traditional activity in the chemistry
classroom for decades or perhaps
centuries let's suppose that you want to
find some property of a chemical let's
say the boiling point of
ethanol you can find it from pubchem
much quicker than from any hardcopy
references but at the end of the day
what you learn from this activity is
still the boiling point of ethanol
regardless of where you find it and the
educational value of this activity is
not very different regardless of what
reference you use then what additional
educational values can pop can provide
compared to the 19th century mercs
index to answer this question we have to
look at pubchem in a different way most
people view pubchem as a singer
information resource but you can also
view pop camp as a gateway to many
information resources in other words pop
camp provides access to all sorts of
chemical information scattered across
hundreds of data sources with that said
the students are now exposed to an
extremely large amount of data so it is
necessary for us to help them to get the
most out of this big chemical
information it means that more emphasis
of chemical education should be given to
chemical information then what can you
teach using Popkin here are some
examples and we are going to review them
briefly during this webinar forest pop
chem can be used to help students to
build the ability to critically assess
chemical data today I'll show you two
examples the first one is about finding
the boiling point of benzene from
pubchem this is a screenshot for the
pubchem compound a summary page for
benzene the compound summary page
provides an aggregated view of all
information available in pubchem for a
given compound if you scroll down this
page you will find the boiling point
section for benzene currently pubchem
has a six boiling point data from five
different sources some sources used
Fahrenheit and others used sensors with
various Precision's and one source
explicitly specified the atmospheric
pressure at which the boiling point was
measured which is good practice and
importantly some gave a single value as
a port boiling point but others gave a
range of values actually one source gave
to a boiling point one as a value and
the other as a range of values what is
going on
if you click these source names the
hidden part is expanded and now you can
see that one is for benzene and the
other is for coal tar and you can see
that there are links to the webpage
where the data was collected from so
what is happening here is that 176 is
the boiling point of benzene but the
other is for coal tar coal tar is a
mixture of various hydrocarbons
including benzene so you can get benzene
from coal tar through distillation
basically coal tar is the natural source
of benzene so some sources used benzene
and Coulter interchangeably and that's
also reflected in pubchem through data
integration so from this example
students can learn that there are
multiple contexts of
a chemical and understand why they are
integrated in a single record and
realize that care should be taken when
searching for chemical data and next
exemplar is about finding caste numbers
for sio2 from pubchem in pubchem sio2
has 22 caste numbers each of these caste
numbers represent a different context of
sio2 depending on whether it means as IO
2 in general or a specific form for
solid sio2 it can be amorphous or
crystalline and the crystalline sio2 can
be further classified into different
polymorphs and the property of sio2
depends on how it is processed and
whether it is pure or it contains as
some contaminants in pubchem all of
these are aggregated into a single
record because they have the same
chemical formula sio2 so again from this
example students can learn the
importance of the context of chemical
data now the second one is about how to
search pop chem by chemical structure
you can type a chemical name into the
Google search box but what would you do
if you don't know the name of the
compound but it's a structure in pubchem
you have two options first you can draw
the structure using molecular drawing
software and code pubchem sketcher or
use a line notation for the structure
several line notations for chemical
structures have been developed but the
most commonly used ones are smiles in
cheese and in turkeys and all of these
are supported in pubchem currently pop
chem has
to structure search interfaces chemical
structure search is older but a stable
interface and pubchem search better it
uses newer technologies but it was
released as a test version you can
access the two structures search
interfaces from the top cam home page
and both interfaces support various
types of search including identity
search substructure superstructure
search and similarity search and
molecular formula search and you can
provide the input structure using the
pubchem compound ID or line notations
like smiles in cheese and indicates and
you can also draw the input structure
using the pubchem sketcher or upload a
file that contains the input structure
and pop cam is actively working on a new
interface that that will replace the two
existing interfaces so please stay tuned
another important topic to cover is a
structure clustering and structural
activity analysis or SAR analysis a
structure clustering is about grouping
compounds into small clusters according
to their structural similarities it is
helpful in classifying molecules
according to their structural
characteristics as an example these are
some anti-allergic agents from pubchem
they can be grouped into three major
clusters like dipeptides glucocorticoids
and antihistamines based on these a
clustering result you can expect that
the anti-allergic activities of these
compounds may come from three different
mechanisms of action and so our analysis
is about clustering compounds
and bio essay data simultaneously it is
useful for identifying structural
characteristics responsible for the bio
activity of molecules
unfortunately the structure clustering
and syrup analysis tools will be retired
by the end of this year but at the same
tasks can still be done using
third-party software after downloading
necessary data from pubchem last one is
automated data retrieval using a
computer code app upcam provides
multiple programmatic access routes
among them park rest is the simplest and
easiest to learn and use and it can be
used with popular programming languages
like Python so students can learn how to
automate data retrieval from pubchem by
writing a short script now let me
briefly talk about care informatics olcc
it was an NSF funded project led by
Professor Belfort at the University of
Arkansas Little Rock and pop Kem was
actively involved in this project as
part of our outreach efforts toward the
chemical education community well
teaching care informatics to
undergraduate chemistry majors has many
unique challenges first care informatics
is not a field of chemistry but a mix of
many different fields because of that
not so many faculty members with Kempe
Mattox expertise who can teach the
course in addition to that there is no
textbook suitable for undergraduate
chemistry majors there are some
cheminformatics textbooks but most of
them are written for computer science
majors or graduate students or covers
somewhat narrow topics that focus
focuses on medicinal chemistry and drug
discovery and cheminformatics of ACC
aimed to address these issues at least
partially in cheminformatics of ACC
confirm addicts experts were recruited
from various places including industry
government and academia and they
prepared online reading materials and
homework problem sets and they were made
available online through the OU SCC
website and the instructors at multiple
participating schools used these online
materials to deliver the chem
informatics course at their schools
concurrently the instructors had faced
face meetings with students in the
classroom at the same time that
cheminformatics experts got engaged in
online discussion with students through
our SEC website we ran this course twice
in fall 2015 we had about 30 students
from four schools and in spring 2017 and
there were about 50 students from 10
schools all the course materials
developed during this course are
available at the Oasis website and liver
texts so if anybody wants to use these
materials for his own course he can use
them for free and many of these course
materials covered pubchem data tools and
services here is a quick summary of
pubchem related topics covered in the
Karen phonetics of ACC and basically it
includes everything that I mentioned
today and more in summary a majority of
pubchem users are likely to be college
student and they use pubchem as a
reference material but there are many
other things that students can do beyond
this use case and upcam can also be used
as a free online informatics education
resource and cheminformatics olcc is a
good example and finally we are very
interested in working together with the
chemical in a chemical education
community so if you're interested please
reach out to us for collaboration thank
you and I'm more than happy to answer
your questions thank you so one will
leave it open for a couple of minutes to
see if there are any questions
looks like we do finally have a couple
of questions so let me get to those real
quick there are two questions that sort
of relate to the same thing so on
what third-party tools can be used to
replicate the SAR functions that are
going to be discontinued and to people
asked simply that question where we are
not allowed to endorse any commercial
software or third-party software so how
we cannot really answer the question in
public but if you send me an email I can
I can tell you about that
in person so one I think it's okay to if
you want to it's okay to mention some
just say specifically we don't endorse
it just an example of one it's fine you
can do that in my opinion our is the
best one because it's free and and it
runs on PC and Mac and Linux and in the
case of our there are many tutorials out
there so you can you can start from
there okay thank you
okay I don't see any additional
questions right now so thanks everybody
for coming and we're having on another
webinar next week on blast so please be
sure to check that out if you're
interested in blast thank you very much
for coming
you